hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's whoopi goldberg on the view being
completely nuts
so as soaring college costs and
crippling student debt keep getting
worse the new yorker magazine writes
about the growing trend of americans who
are still paying off loans well into
their retirement age even a 91 year old
woman who owes more than 300 000
from a debt that started out as 39 yeah
thousand okay people who are in their
70s and 80s may not be making the same
money they made in their 50s and 60s you
need to forgive this yeah you need to
forgive this this is ridiculous no slam
on young people but if you have worked
your behind off you've tried to move
yourself up the ladder you talk about
people can't get gas they can't buy food
they can't put their children through
through any kind of college that's
because they're paying off these
freaking student debts
i'll tell you what wait
just consider this
get rid of the interest let people pay
back yes what they borrowed yeah and let
us go from there but do something about
this because you're mutton up a whole
slew of americans that don't deserve
this at this late state in their life